para estos militares de lugones como
para estos presidentes de la región
vecina de idóneas el voto para saber si
están A favor o no de la anexión de su
región a Rusia está muy claro
la perspectivas eran mucho mejor que
bajo Ucrania Esa es mi opinión
todo irá bien con la ayuda de Dios todo
el mundo volverá construiremos nuestra
ciudad
a partir de hoy hasta el martes estos
referéndum se celebran en cuatro zonas
geográficas es decir el 15% del
territorio ucraniano a las repúblicas
separatistas de idóneaskia lugones se
suman las regiones ocupadas desde
apurilla y Herson afuera de las
fronteras los ciudadanos ucranianos
también empezaron a votar como esta
mujer originaria de sapurilla que vive
en la ciudad rusa de caborovsky
He estado esperando ansiosamente para
unirme a la federación rusa debido a los
recientes acontecimientos en Ucrania
vivir allá ha sido imposible desde 2014
Ojalá hubiéramos tenido el apoyo de
Rusia mucho antes estoy muy agradecida
de que estos referendos hayan comenzado
pero no todos los habitantes de estas
regiones están a favor de los eferendos
estas personas huyeron de la violencia
en gerson y ahora han desplazadas dicen
que no quieren formar parte de Rusia
puedes arrancar ilegalmente una parte de
Ucrania vienen a casa de otros y hacen
lo que le está la gana no lo apoyo
estoy en contra del referendo creo que
mi ciudad y mi región pertenecen
plenamente a Ucrania
una mayoría a favor de la anexión podría
dar a músculo las herramientas para
afirmar que cualquier acción militar
ucraniana anestos territorios constituye
un ataque a la propia Rusia las
votaciones continuarán hasta el martes
27 de septiembre